[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
doomsday mom lori valo day bell indicted
for another death
already charged in the murders of her
two children now accused in the murder
of her former husband
charles valor and bill cosby is released
from prison
why the pennsylvania supreme court
overturned the disgraced comedian's
conviction
plus smallville actor alison mack is
sentenced to three years in prison
for her role in the sex cult nexium and
a grand jury to investigate the surfside
condo collapse
we asked the experts who can be held
responsible what options do surviving
victims and family members have
the legal implications of the
heartbreaking disaster law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the death toll continues to rise in
surfside florida
and as search crews continue their
efforts more questions are being asked
about the legal implications of the
deadly condo collapse
it is such painstaking grueling work
as crews removed more than 3 million
pounds of debris the miami-dade state
attorney has announced a grand jury
investigation
into what may be the deadliest
accidental building collapse in u.s
history
the mayor of miami-dade county pledging
her support i will do and my team will
do everything possible
to aid them in their efforts
to continue that investigation senior
prosecutors are on the scene at the
disaster site
to collaborate with engineers and
investigators dump trucks are moving
rubble to an evidence debris collection
site
we're relocating it to a location we'll
be also collected sift through
a catalog photograph for future
investigative purposes
but as a process continued loved ones
are searching for answers
a newly released email from the april by
the board of directors for the champlain
towers
shows residents were told that damage
discovered in 2018
got significantly worse the estimated
cost of repairs had jumped from 9
million dollars
to 15 million dollars individual condo
owners were set to begin payments on
july 1st
and the miami herald obtaining photos
taken just 36 hours
before the collapse of the pool
equipment room showing exposed rebar
and wet floors shocking video captured
the moments the building collapsed
the following day the first lawsuit of
what's expected to be many was filed
the class action suit against the
building association seeks more than
5 million dollars in damages saying
champlain towers failed to safeguard the
lives and property
of the residents and as rescue efforts
continue from day seven into day eight
more than 200 people are working on the
mound i can't emphasize enough
you know the dangers that we're
encountering the florida rain washing in
as fires creep up in surfside
so many questions so few answers joining
me now is condominium law attorney kevin
herzl kevin let's get drum right into it
who can be sued
and how can the surviving victims and
loved ones recover
just some of their terrible losses
that's a very interesting question brian
so thus far the lawsuits they've been
pointed at the condo association
so one of the central issues that's
going to come up here is whether or not
there's insurance coverage
in these cases it's debatable whether
there's going to be insurance coverage
for a building collapse
if there is no insurance coverage and
the association has sued
the owners the residents the estates of
these people would have to pay an
assessment to do that
so in effect these lawsuits they may end
up essentially suing themselves
interesting now kevin this is far out of
my wheelhouse as a public defender but i
know
statute of limitations the time frame in
which a person can file a suit
this could prevent some people from
filing claims against the condo right
probably not against the condo because
their actions happened in the last
couple years with respect to the repairs
certainly there are other responsible
parties such as the developer that the
statute of limitations may long since
have expired
depending on whether this was properly
put together from the get-go
there may be issues with the city and
the inspections they told them that this
property was okay
but they're protected by governmental
immunity now certainly depending on
who provided what advice when with
respect to the engineers you know
there may be issues there as well that
are eventually going to be looked at
here too
sounds like a lot of investigation as to
who may be on the hook and who can get
pulled
in let's bring in co-host terry austin
for more
terry what type of claims and arguments
do you see
when a condo collapses like this i think
there's going to be years and years of
litigation there's going to be
negligence claims wrongful death
and kevin is absolutely correct there
will be claims against the association
but
also there will be claims against the
developers the owners the managers
anyone who had anything to do
with the collapse of this building and
if they were negligent meaning they owed
a duty to the residents of this building
and we know for a fact that we're seeing
reports
where they're saying that there was
damage to the property it needed to be
maintained
and clearly that was not done here so
there will be some recovery for sure
from most of these individuals
who are bringing the claims yeah at
least some of these photos and videos
seem to be starting the groundwork
sorry no pun intended for kind of
developing what could be a very serious
lawsuit now kevin
these seem like civil uh allegations
that could be coming out of this case
are there any potential for there being
criminal liability maybe recklessness or
criminal negligence against some of
these parties
a grand jury has been convened but i
think it's highly unlikely that there
would be any criminal liability
there was a building that collapsed in
new york about a year ago
a similar type of process and no
criminal charges has been brought
forward
in that particular case but the one
thing that's really important
to realize here is we don't even know
what caused this yet a causation for
either a civil or a criminal lawsuit
is going to be extremely important so
unless somebody has an expert report
that can establish what caused this
which nobody has yet
nobody really has any business bringing
a civil lawsuit or bringing criminal
charges until those investigations are
complete
yeah it sounds like you're bringing me
back to my law school days of paul's
graph of
but for causation terry any other
insight that we can get into this
collapse of the building that might give
us an indication
that civil charges may be coming out of
this grand jury investigation
well i think every time we hear about
some notice that has been given
to the parties involved we know for a
fact that they have reached some duty of
care if they knew that there was an
issue with the building and with the
structure of that building so
when you hear reports about years ago
they gave them notification that there
was a problem that they knew that there
was water
we're going to see lawsuits coming for
sure all right kevin thank you for
lending your expertise here and kind of
giving us the up and down as to what
could happen in the surf side condo
collapse
still ahead on law and crime daily are
criminal charges looming against members
of the trump organization
but first laurie vallo day bell indicted
in the death of one of her husbands
charles valo's warning to police about
the now infamous doomsday mom
just months before he was shot and
killed next
[Music]
welcome back more legal trouble for
laurie vallo day bell
a grand jury in phoenix has indicted the
so-called doomsday cult mom
on a conspiracy charge in the murder of
her ex-husband
angelia levy is here with new details
about the bizarre case
yeah brian lori vallo's brother alex cox
told police
straight up that he shot charles valo in
self-defense
cox is now dead and his sister is now
accused and charged with conspiring him
to
with him to murder charles valo
january 31st 2020 charles vallo called
police in chandler arizona
about his estranged wife lori valo she's
just
lost touch with me i'm not me she yells
she's just it's just she's unhappy
charles was trying to get a mental
health evaluation for
lori he said she had made threats
she's had a break she says i'm
nick schneider i've taken over charles's
body
and charles has been killed i'm gonna
kill you you're going to be murdered
today or tomorrow
earlier that day lori valo and her
daughter tyler ryan
went to another police department to
report that charles had stolen her purse
my friend that's a police officer he
said go file a reporter either returning
i don't want to do all that stuff i just
wanted to be on record and if you can
get the purse back that would be lovely
because all my stuff is in there i'm
really mad about my lip gloss
nearly six months later police were
called to a home lori valo was renting
by her brother alex cox alex told police
he had shot charles he came with me with
a bat
was he living here or no visiting he
came to pick up his son
okay is his son inside no my sister took
him to school
lori and daughter tylie would return to
the home lori appearing to giggle at
times on police body camera footage
two months later tyler and her younger
brother j.j valo would go missing
leading to a massive search for the
children all
eyes turn to laurie vallo and her new
husband chad dabell
an author considered by many to be a
cult leader
lori valodebel and chad day bell are now
charged with murdering tyler ryan jj
valo
and chad's former wife tammy laurie has
been deemed incompetent to stand trial
i'm sure that if you ask the prosecutor
they would say
that they are seeking justice for a
victim and
some sort of closure on behalf of the
victim nonetheless it
sort of looks like a public relations
endeavor
when the truth of the matter is lori
valo will never see an arizona court
ring
until all of the idaho charges against
her have been
conclusively resolved jason lamb
practices law in maricopa county arizona
where lori valo dabel now faces
charges alex cox died in december 2019
of natural causes it suggests that
prosecutors
have evidence from the investigation
that the two of them conspired or
agreed to commit the murder that's
charged in this latest
arizona indictment
lori valo dabal is currently receiving
mental health treatment in
idus so she can be restored to
competency
so her criminal case is right now on
hold
brian jeanette let's bring in co-host
terry austin for more on lori
valodebel's newest indictment
terry conspiracy to commit murder with a
now deceased
man alex cox how do you think that will
work if this case does in fact go to
trial
it's not going to work very well but i
think what the prosecutors will do
is point the finger to alex clearly he
was the
one who pulled the trigger and we know
for a fact that
laurie davil was behind it as well she
was there
she told the police and you saw in that
clip that she was telling the police
beforehand
that charles valo was really a problem
and that she was okay and that
you know the police didn't need to worry
about any of the things that charles
valo was saying but here in fact we see
lori's brother alex shoot him and it was
not
in self-defense and finally now we are
seeing that the authorities are bringing
charges against both of them
so i think the prosecutors will point
the finger at alex even though he
is a dead man and they will still have
evidence
showing that he was the one who actually
shot
boy valo's husband charles yeah i'm
expecting some kind of text messages
phone calls communication that they can
show
to show that agreement to make this
decision uh to kill her ex-husband
and jeanette did it police in the
phoenix area also review the death
of another ex-husband of laurie valodebo
yeah and she has four husbands just in
case our viewers don't know
joseph ryan he was the third husband or
really maybe the second husband but he
died in 2018 and after he died
all of these things unfold all of these
people die and then
they're indicted for these other murders
in idaho with the children and tammy
dabal
well then a tape surfaces where
she spoke about wanting to kill joseph
ryan
so they went back and they reviewed it
they just wanted to make sure they had
all of their eyes dotted and their t's
crossed and they determined yet again
that that was a death of natural causes
interesting could have been a third or i
guess at this point fifth
murder charge against lori valedevo
we'll keep eyes on that case
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily former actor turned sex cult
accomplice alison mack
finds out how much time she's going to
spend behind bars
plus bill cosby is out of prison why
charges are now being dropped against
the disgraced comedian after the break
[Music]
welcome back let's check in on some top
legal news at the law and crime network
including criminal charges expected
against members of the trump
organization
sources say the manhattan district
attorney's office will likely file
charges
thursday against former president donald
trump's company and
his chief financial officer the wall
street journal first reportedly expected
charges which are not expected against
president trump himself
the da's office is investigating trump's
family business for alleged french
benefits the company awarded
to a top executive the charges would be
a first for the investigation
into president trump and his former
dealings
former smallville actress alison mack
has been sentenced to three years for
her role in the sex call
nexium a federal judge called mack both
a slave and a master
to convicted cult leader keith renee
renery is currently serving a 120 year
sentence
for a series of crimes including forced
labor human trafficking and sex
trafficking prosecutors are now
revealing mack helped cooperate to bring
renery down
just a month before his trial mack
produced a recording of the cult leader
instructing her
to hold a woman down almost like a
sacrifice
we'll bring you more in the case
tomorrow as one of the victims and
whistleblowers joins law and crime daily
and bill cosby is now a free man the
pennsylvania supreme court has issued an
opinion
vacating the disgraced comedian's
conviction cosby's defense attorney
successfully argued
prosecutors violated his constitutional
right the first prosecutor overseeing
the case had
reached a non-prosecutorial agreement
with cosby if he agreed to testify
in a civil lawsuit against accuser
andrea constand in 2005.
a new prosecutor brought criminal
charges against cosby in 2015
using those words against him the
commonwealth's highest court ruled
wednesday that the previous agreement
must be upheld and the 83 year old
cannot be retried
cosby has always maintained his
innocence
now terry from what i understand of
reading the court documents the state
supreme court seems to have overturned
the conviction
based on the violation of cosby's fifth
amendment right what did you make about
this decision
and the result well i think it was
probably the right decision but i think
many people are going to be
disappointed with the result
particularly the victims
of bill cosby so what the court did here
is they said because of this
non-prosecution
agreement bill cosby was promised
that he would not have claims brought
against him
and he said that okay then i will
testify at this deposition
and i will have immunity that did not
happen
claims were brought against him he was
charged
and the supreme court of pennsylvania
said no you can't do that
you can't go back on this promise and so
they vacated the conviction right
decision
but sadly it was the wrong result like
many people agree with you once they
kind of dig
deep into this opinion by the court
thank you terry
let's check in on what chief
investigative correspondent brian ross
is working on this week thanks brian
coming up this week on brian ross
investigates
new developments in a major story we
first reported last month
about allegations of sexual abuse and
cover-up
at a summer camp once thought to be one
of the most wonderful camps in the
country
i said no countless times and eventually
got so
um scared of him
that i reported him directly to the camp
manager
since our report the ceo of the camp has
now resigned and more steps are about to
be taken
that's this week on brian ross
investigates on the long crime
trial network brian
thanks brian ross when we come back we
discuss the latest in colorado versus
mark redwine
trial the testimony from the deputy who
found dylan redwine's remains
and the phone call the father accused of
murder made a day after his son went
missing
next
welcome back we're now hearing from a
dear friend and former attorney to
robert durst
as the millionaire stands trial for the
murder of his best friend
robert durst is accused of shooting
susan berman in december of 2000.
burma was found dead in her california
home with a bullet wound in the back of
her head
pre-recorded video testimony from stuart
altman was played in court
allman is a long-time friend and former
attorney of the real estate air
altman says that in 2015 durst told
altman that durst shaved his head on
purpose
to show people the shanton stall to
drain fluid in his skull
this testimony was played shortly after
the prosecutor accused durst
of trying to get sympathy from the jury
which he passionately denies
now onto colorado where her father is on
trial for the murder of his 13-year-old
son
dylan redwine went missing in november
2012 while on a court mandated visit to
his father mark redwine
dinless said to have discovered explicit
photos of his father
dressing in women's lingerie and eating
feces from a diaper
the teen's remains were found a short
distance from the father's home in
colorado
and the skull was found three years
after he went missing
do you receive information about items
of evidentiary value on middle mountain
yes can you tell us about that
attempt that there was a human skull
found
up the road from the dump site on
middle mountain and as he started to
cross
the drainage his foot went in the water
and he stumbled and then he found
the skull and he picked it up and what
did you do
well he picked it up and raised it over
his head like this and yelled
skull and i laid my
eyes on it and i just
flew across the creek and i took it from
him and i gently set it on the ground
the deputy also testified to phone
records she found during her
investigation of mark redwine
that showed he called his lawyer the day
after his son went missing
were you able to isolate or identify a
telephone number belonging to
mark redwine's attorney yes so then i
called her back again
and i advised who i was why i was
calling her and asked if she knew
who mark redwine was and she said
that she didn't feel comfortable talking
about that
okay were you able to determine
eventually that this was her attorney
his attorney excuse me yes
now and jeannette the search for dylan
redwine was huge over 900
tips was this witness helpful in laying
out where dylan redwine's
remains were found yeah i think she was
and she gave a lot of detailed
information she went up to the map and
she was showing where
what was found where and what they did
on that search and the tips that were
taken in she said
when she was ever if she ever made it to
the witness stand in this case
she wanted to be able to say that they
did everything that they absolutely
could
to figure out where dylan was and what
happened to him
definitely tried to get that sentiment
across but terry on the opposite side of
the defense
tried to poke holes in the investigation
maybe to suggest that it wasn't as
thorough
as the prosecution wants the jury to
believe how do you think that played out
i don't think it played out very well i
think tonya goldbrite and daniel
patterson the two investigators on the
scene
did an excellent job i think it was
thorough i think they
roped off the scene the way they should
have the defense was trying to say that
it wasn't roped off properly defense was
trying to say
the evidence wasn't collected property
they were trying to say that it wasn't
logged properly and i think both of them
testified that all of these things were
done
to the fullest extent possible they
didn't rope off the scene because they
had to get down off the mountain because
of the weather
and they did collect the property and
they did identify it so
i definitely don't think that there were
many holes poked in
to the prosecution's case yeah and that
call to a lawyer is not looking very
good right now kind of consciousness of
guilt
thank you both and thank you for joining
us here on law and crime daily we'll see
you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you